,
CANCELING STUDENT DEBT.
IF GOT TO DO THAT.
HERE WITH REACTION AS
PROFESSOR OF BUSINESS AND
ECONOMICS AT THE KING'S COLLEGE
IN MANHATTAN, FOX NEWS
CONTRIBUTOR AND FORMER NEIGHBOR
OF MINE WHEN WE WERE IN
FIFTH GRADE, BRIAN BREMMER.
AND FOX NEWS CONTRIBUTOR, PHIL
FLYNN.
BRIAN, GREAT TO SEE YOU.
ADDING THIS ALL UP, IT ALMOST
MAKES ME FEEL LIKE -- HERE WE
ARE, NEVER LET A CRISIS GO TO
WASTE.
YOU ARE GOING TO FEEL THE PAIN.
WE DON'T HAVE THE ANSWER, BUT
THE ANSWER IS MORE PAIN TO THIS
PERFECT GREEN FUTURE.
YOU ARE JUST GOING TO HAVE TO
WAIT A WHILE FOR IT AND SUFFER
IN THE PROCESS.
>> THIS IS A PROBLEM.
IT DOESN'T ADD UP.
THE PRESIDENT IS DOUBLING DOWN
ON THE WRONG HAND.
WE HAVE SEEN THIS PLAY OUT
BEFORE.
THAT IS WHAT WE HAVE WATCHED IN
EUROPE FOR THE BETTER PART OF
TWO DECADES.
THEY HAVE TRIED TO DOUBLE DOWN
ON GREEN ENERGY AND IT LEFT THEM
DEPENDENT ON A DICTATOR.
WE ARE GOING TO END UP IN THE
EXACT SAME KIND OF SPOT IF WE
KEEP GOING DOWN THE GREEN
RELIGION PATH THAT THAT HE IS
GOING DOWN.
A RELIGION THAT DEMAND SACRIFICE
IS NOT INTERESTED IN GROWTH,
ISN'T INTERESTED IN GETTING
WEALTHIER SO WE CAN INNOVATE
CLEANER TECHNOLOGIES.
IT WANTS AMERICANS TO PAY UP.
THIS IS THE WRONG APPROACH.
HE CAN GIVE YOU ALL THE NUMBERS,
BUT AT THIS POINT, THE PRESIDENT
COMPLETELY LACKS ANY STRATEGIC
DIRECTION ON HELPING AMERICANS.
ONE GETS THE IMPRESSION, AND YOU
CAN SEE THIS IN THE POLLS,
AMERICANS THINK THIS.
ONE GETS THE IMPRESSION OF THE
PRESIDENT LIKING THESE HIGHER
PRICES BECAUSE HE DOESN'T WANT
TO LET THIS CRISIS GO TO WASTE
AND HE IS WILLING TO PUT IT ON
THE BACKS OF AMERICAN FAMILIES.
>> IT'S AMAZING.
GIVE ME THOSE NUMBERS.
THERE ARE ALTERNATIVES AND WAYS
WE COULD FIND THE ENERGY
RESOURCES REQUIRED TO BOTH
SUPPORT OURSELVES AND GET BACK
TO ENERGY INDEPENDENCE AND
ENERGY DOMINANCE, BUT ALSO
SUPPORT EUROPE AS IT SEEKS TO
CUT ITSELF OFF FROM RUSSIA AS
WELL.
ARE WE GOING TO DO ANY OF THOSE
THINGS?
>> WE SHOULD.
WE HAVE ENOUGH NATURAL GAS IN
THE GROUND TO SUPPLY THE U.S.
AND EUROPE, MAY BE FOR 100-200
YEARS.
WITH NEW TECHNOLOGIES AND
INNOVATION, EVEN MORE THAN THAT.
BUT WHAT I FIND AMAZING ABOUT
THIS, HERE IS PRESIDENT BIDEN
SAYING HE'S GOING TO DOUBLE DOWN
ON HIS GREEN ENERGY POLICY, BUT
THEN WHEN THEY GET INTO TROUBLE,
THEY CALL ON THE U.S. ENERGY
INDUSTRY TO SAVE THEIR
BACKSIDES, RIGHT?
WHAT IS THAT ALL ABOUT?
IT'S LIKE HEY, WE ARE GOING TO
SEND YOU GOOD OLD FASHION
AMERICAN MADE FROM AMERICA TO
SAVE THE DAY BEARD WHO MADE
THAT?
IT WAS THE U.S. ENERGY.
YOU CAN'T GET A FEDERAL LEASE
THESE DAYS.
I WONDER IF THEY CALLED THE
ENERGY COMPANY -- ARE THEY GOING
TO BUY THIS ENERGY AND THEN GIVE
IT TO EUROPE?
ARE THEY GOING TO DICTATE WHO WE
SELL THIS TO?
LISTEN, THE U.S. ENERGY INDUSTRY
IS MORE READY AND WILLING TO
GROW THEIR BUSINESS SO THEY CAN
DO THIS IN THE FUTURE, BUT NOT
WITH JOE BIDEN IN OFFICE WHEN
EVERY STEP OF THE WAY THEY GET
IN THEIR WAY OF DOING WHAT THEY
WANT TO DO.
>> I DON'T KNOW IF YOU HAD THE
PREVIOUS SEGMENT, BUT I WAS
TALKING TO MATT SCHLAPP AND HE
SAID, WHAT WE DO?
AND HE SAID, WAIT THREE YEARS.
HE WAS SHORT OF JOKING, BUT
THAT'S THE FEELING A LOT OF
AMERICANS HAVE RIGHT NOW.
IT DOESN'T FEEL LIKE THE CAVALRY
IS COMING.
SO IF WE HAD NO OIL AND GAS AND
NUCLEAR -- IF WE EVER EXPLORE
THAT -- BUT IF WE DO ACTUAL OIL
AND GAS AND WE ARE NOT GOING TO
DO IT, THEN WHAT HAPPENS FOR THE
NEXT THREE YEARS FOR AMERICA?
>> WE KEEP PAYING OUT.
THAT IS THE PROBLEM HERE THAT IS
WHY PEOPLE ARE SO PESSIMISTIC
ABOUT THEIR ECONOMIC SITUATION
RIGHT NOW.
THEY ARE NOT PESSIMISTIC BECAUSE
THEY THINK THE AMERICAN ECONOMY
CANNOT BE BRAVE, THEY ARE
PESSIMISTIC BECAUSE THEY'VE GOT
A PRESIDENT WHO HAS NO PLAN FOR
GETTING OUT OF THIS.
HE HAS A PLAN FOR DIGGING DEEPER
INTO THIS.
WE NEED SOME HELP, WE NEED A
PRESIDENT TO GO OUT ON AMERICAN
SOIL AND TO SPEAK TO AMERICAN
OIL AND GAS PRODUCERS AND SAY,
WE ARE DOUBLING DOWN ON YOUR
PRODUCTION.
PIPELINE.
WE ARE GOING TO BECOME
INDEPENDENT, NOT JUST FOR OUR
SAKE, BUT FOR THE SAKE OF THE
WORLD.
EUROPE DEPENDS ON THIS.
FRANKLY THEY NEED A RESCUE RIGHT
NOW AND THE ONLY COUNTRY ON
PLANET EARTH THAT CAN DO THAT IS
THE UNITED STATES OF AMERICA.
BUT WE'VE GOT TO HAVE A
PRESIDENT, BECAUSE NOBODY
BELIEVES THAT HE WANTS TO SEE
THIS INDUSTRY THRIVE.
THE BANKS DON'T BELIEVE IT, THE
PRODUCERS DON'T BELIEVE IT, THE
PIPELINE INFRASTRUCTURE GUYS
DON'T BELIEVE IT.
HE'S GOT TO GO OUT THERE AND
STAND UP TO EVERYBODY IN THIS
COUNTRY HAS BEEN TELLING ME TO
DOUBLE DOWN ON GREEN ENERGY AND
INSTEAD I'M GOING TO DOUBLE DOWN
ON AMERICAN PRODUCTION OF OIL
AND GAS.
THAT IS AT.
OTHERWISE IT IS THREE YEARS OF
THE SAME THING WE'VE SEEN FOR
THE LAST THREE MONTHS.
>> PHIL, ON THE CAMPAIGN TRAIL,
JOE BIDEN SAID REPEATEDLY THAT
HE WANTS TO END FOSSIL FUELS.
HE WAS GOING AFTER THE OIL AND
GAS INDUSTRY, HE WAS GOING AFTER
FRACKING, HE WAS GOING AFTER
ENERGY.
LET'S JUST SAY, IF HE AND HIS
LEFTIST FRIENDS GOT WHAT THEY
WANTED IN THEIR CLIMATE AGENDA,
WHAT WOULD THAT DO TO WHAT WE
ARE ACTUALLY FACING RIGHT NOW IS
A COUNTRY?
WHAT WOULD THAT ACTUALLY MEAN?
>> WE WOULD LOOK AT THESE AS THE
GOOD OLD DAYS.
THEY ARE PLANNED -- IF YOU DO
THE MATH ON WHAT THEY ARE TRYING
TO ACCOMPLISH, IT IS SIMILAR TO
WHAT IS HAPPENING IN EUROPE AND
EUROPE IS ONLY A PREVIEW OF WHAT
IS GOING TO HAPPEN.
NATURAL GAS, AT THE PEAK, GOT TO
THE BE THE EQUIVALENT OF $600 A
BARREL THIS YEAR.
YOU CAN IMAGINE GASOLINE PRICES
IN CALIFORNIA ARE ALREADY CLOSE
TO $7 A GALLON WITH OIL -- AT
104.
COULD YOU IMAGINE WHAT THEY
WOULD BE IF OIL PRICES WERE UP
TO 600?
SO THIS IS JUST CRAZINESS.
LISTEN.
AT THE END OF THE DAY WHEN YOU
ARE TALKING ABOUT THE GREEN
ENERGY DEAL, WE NEED TO PULL
BACK FROM THIS, BECAUSE WHAT IT
IS -- IT IS A DEAL THAT WILL
UNDERMINE THE U.S. ECONOMY.
THIS IS A DEEP AND ABOUT
CLEANING THE ENVIRONMENT,
BECAUSE IF YOU REALLY GO THROUGH
THESE ENERGY THINGS -- THE
UNITED STATES IS ACTUALLY
PRODUCING GREENHOUSE GAS
EMISSIONS BETTER THAN ANYBODY IN
THE PARIS CLIMATE ACCORD.
>> AS IT PERTAINS TO ENERGY
DOMINANCE, IT WAS RONALD REAGAN
IN THE 80s WHO WARNED GERMANY
IF YOU DEPEND ON SOVIET ENERGY,
IF YOU APPROVE NORDSTROM ONE,
YOU'RE GOING TO BE BEHOLDEN TO
THEM SOMEDAY IN THE FUTURE.
HERE WE ARE, TRUMP WARNED OF THE
SAME THING.
BIDEN DIDN'T END HERE WE ARE.
THAT IS WHY MANY PEOPLE,
INCLUDING MY COHOST ON
"FOX & FRIENDS" WEEKEND, CALLS
THIS THE GREEN NEW DEAL WAR.
ETHIC IT'S PRETTY TOUG